(audience applauds)
- 70's inspired, yeah,
it's nice, it's nice.
Meet Joshua, have y'all met before?
- We have not.
- No.
- It's nice to meet you too.
- I like that we all got the, the vibes.
- I, yeah, I was like, somebody
gave us the little bit of...
- I was almost gonna wear
those shoes, I'm glad I...
- These are J.Lo's shoes.
- I chose these instead.
Her actual shoes?
- They, well, she has a, a new line.
- Oh.
- Her shoe line.
So, they're JLO by J.Lo.
- Do you know what I like about them?
Is that they're not, like
it, it's a pretend heel.
- [Christine] Yes.
Like, it's like, it's a platform.
I love a platform, because
it's raised up already.
- Yeah and it's very easy to walk in,
so you can borrow them anytime.
- Way easier than stilettos.
- Excellent.
- Yeah.
(Christine laughs)
You wouldn't know, because you're a man.
(audience laughs)
Anyway, so, I mean, I'm
not bitter about it.
- It's okay, I'll just
move one more seat over.
(Kelly laughs)
- Just kidding.
No, this is your first talk show, right?
Yes, this is my first one.
- [Kelly] I didn't know, that's exciting.
(audience applauds)
When, do you remember
your first talk show?
- I, the first talk show that
I remember being on is TRL,
which some people...
- Oh, my God.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I loved TRL.
- [Kelly] I was on TRL,
I've been around for that long, yeah.
- I called in to TRL.
- But we're going like 25 years ago now.
But it was, it was a lot more
anxiety inducing than this,
I'm just gonna say.
(Christine laughs)
- Oh, my God, they would scream so loud.
Everybody in this small,
little room, yeah.
- I would fight over
Backstreet Boys and NSYNC
winning the top spot, so.
(Kelly laughs)
- I think we were there
honestly with NSYNC or,
yeah I think we were there with NSYNC.
- I would've died.
- As you can imagine, it was.
- Thank God, I'm meeting
you years later...
- Oh, my God, the decibel of...
- Because I wouldn't have kept my cool.
(Christine laughs)
- Frequency of scream,
yeah, that's interesting.
Wait, you have an interesting background.
- [Christine] Yes.
- Is it, you grew up in Chicago,
you grew up in Taiwan and Atlanta?
- Yep, I was born in Chicago...
- [Kelly] That's random.
(audience applauds)
- Yes, Chi town.
And then, like, I think
when I was two weeks old,
my mom put me on a plane
and I moved to Taiwan.
And then, when I was three
I moved to Acworth, Georgia
and I grew up in Georgia.
- What in the world?
It's the craziest like,
coolest experience.
Like...
- Yeah.
- So, you ended up mostly in Georgia?
- Yes.
- Growing up.
- So, I was actually
adopted by my mom's sister.
- Oh.
- So, I was adopted into my aunt's family.
And my mom's actually in the
industry and so was my dad,
so I would watch my parents
on Chinese TV growing up.
- What? That's so interesting.
- [Christine] It was really wild.
Like, they weren't there for
parent-teacher conferences
and I'd tell all my friends, I'm like,
"They're on TV, in Taiwan".
And they're like, "Sure".
(audience laughs)
- Yeah.
- Like, they are.
- Oh my gosh, that's so interesting.
My sister actually lived
with my aunt for a long,
a long period.
- Oh, really?
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Same thing.
- It's like in the family.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But still like, I'm
lucky I have two moms.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, I call her mom.
- Love is love man.
Anybody willing to love
you and put up with you,
especially as a teenager.
(Kelly and audience chuckles)
- [Christine] Oh.
- So wait, your show is called "Dave".
So, what's it about?
- Yes.
- "Dave" is after Dave Bird
and it's pretty much just, about a man
who grew up always wanting
to be the best rapper alive.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, and he took his bar mitzvah money
and made music videos.
And these music videos went viral
and then, he became a really big rapper.
So, basically this is loosely based
on his life and it's about Lil Dicky.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh, okay.
So, you must have some pretty cool
like, musical moments
on the show then, right?
- Oh, my gosh, there's so many artists
that come on our show.
And it's really fun, because I play Emma,
who's his friend from when he
used to work at an ad agency.
And that's kind of, where
he came up with the idea
like, maybe I could be a rapper,
because I'm creative
and I like to perform.
- Yeah.
- And so, basically I'm his friend
that like encourages him
to follow this dream.
And because of that, we kind of like,
go behind the scenes and
meet a bunch of producers
and other singers.
And so, we've had Justin
Bieber on our show.
- Oh, wow.
- Whoo, whoo.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
And this season, because
from, I'm from Georgia,
we have Usher on the show.
- Oh.
(audience applauds)
Let me say, that man.
I mean, you are, you
are stunning too, but.
(Christine laughs)
But when I, when I, I was like,
"Usher's gonna be on, do I
have any scenes with him?"
They were like, "No".
And I'm like, "Okay, fine".
- Can you create one?
- Can you please just like, write it in?
But, we shared, like our
trailers were next to each other.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that morning, when I walked out,
he was just like, standing
there outside my trailer.
I don't know why, but he
smiled the most beautiful smile
and he was like, "Hi, how are you?"
And I was like, "Hi, it's
so nice to meet you".
And I freaked out and it was wonderful.
He was so kind and I was like,
"That's it, that's all I need".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then they told me, they were like,
"Hey, we're adding in a
scene where Emma dances
with a big group of people
and Usher's gonna dance with you".
And I was like...
(Christine gasps)
And I was like, "Oh, my gosh".
And my character's like, really
cool and calm and collected,
but let me tell you, when
we shot those scenes...
- You were like...
- I'm like this, I'm like...
(audience and Kelly chuckle)
- [Kelly] Like, I cannot act.
- [Christine] I was like, I,
I'm not even acting right now,
but, and I got to hug him and, and they,
there's a behind the scenes
photos, photo of us hugging.
And so, I'm still trying
to locate that photo,
but when I get it, I'm framing it.
- When I get it.
- Yeah.
(Kelly and Christine chuckle)
- That sounds fun.
It sounds like a fun,
creative environment.
- Honestly, I mean this season is so fun,
because we go on tour and I'm sure like,
when you're on tour there's a
lot of fun things that happen.
We go to a bunch of different cities.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, we start in Lubbock, Texas.
- Been there.
- Been there, really?
- Yeah, I'm from Texas, so yeah.
- [Christine] Wonderful.
- I've toured pretty much most places.
- Everywhere.
- Yeah.
(Christine and Kelly chuckle)
Did you actually get on the tour bus
and see like, the bunks
and, I call them coffins.
- Okay, so...
- Okay.
- Because this is a show
about Lil Dicky and there're,
it's hip hop centric...
- Yeah.
- That is not the cleanest
tour bus, I will say.
- Just so you know...
(Christine laughs)
Most aren't.
(group laughs)
Like when dudes are involved.
- Yeah, it's very like, sticky,
because Coke is spilled
everywhere and nobody cleans up.
It's a very fascinating tour bus.
- And like, it's a bus and it's moving.
So, dudes waking up to pee
at night, just so you know.
- Yep, it's, it's just everywhere.
It's not conducive for women.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And that's pretty much, what
you're gonna see in the show,
but it's very fun.
- Yeah.
- And, and we just have a
lot of cool guest stars.
I will say...
- That's cool.
- If you make it to the finale,
you're gonna be shocked
by who is in our show.
People who have not done
TV before are in our show.
- Oh, what a good tease.
- That's the tease.
- That's an amazing tease.
- Now, you have to make the finale.
Yeah, that was a really great...
- So, now I'm just forcing you to watch
all 10 episodes basically, on Hulu.
- To get to the finale, yeah.